Hi, I'm Andrew Bowers,
product manager
for developer products
at Google.
I'd like to talk to you
about Google Web Toolkit.
Browsers are capable
of a lot these days,
but to take full advantage
of the browser
you need to be an expert
in JavaScript
and three or more browsers
and their quirks,
and potentially have
a lot of time on your hands.
Alternatively, you could
have a good set of tools
to help you out.
Google Web Toolkit provides
a set of tools for just that.
It lets a developer write
an AJAX application
in the Java programming
language,
taking advantage of all the
tools available for Java,
and then cross-compiles that
code into highly optimized,
plain old JavaScript.
JavaScript that's not only
optimized per browser,
but can be served
from any web server.
Let's see what development with
Google Web Toolkit looks like.
Let's look at one of the
App Engine demo applications
that uses Google Web Toolkit,
or GWT for short.
It's a sticky note application
that allows surfaces
to be shared among
logged-in users.
I'll go into Eclipse
and open up this project.
The source package structure
is divided
into client
and server packages.
At deploy time, Java files
in the client directory
will be cross-compiled
into JavaScript,
and run
in our users' browsers.
Files in the server directory
will be run as bytecode
on the server.
Because my client code
is also modeled in Java,
I have the option
of using the same objects
across both my server
and my JavaScript client.
GWT provides higher-level
abstraction
on top of JavaScript,
enabling developers
to be more productive
by coding against widgets
and events that work across
all major browsers.
It's worth noting
that you can also mix
handwritten JavaScript
into GWT source code easily.
But for now, I'm just focusing
on the Java aspects.
Part of the development-time
magic of GWT
is the hosted mode browser.
During development, you interact
with your application
in the hosted mode browser,
which runs your Java bytecode
on the backend to render
your user interface
in an embedded browser.
This has two benefits.
First, because we're running
Java bytecode,
it means you can debug as you
would any Java applications,
setting breakpoints,
inspecting variables,
and stepping through code.
I'll set break points...
create a new note
to trigger one of them...
and then inspect the variable
containing the note contents.
Second, you can develop
using the familiar
edit-refresh-view
programming model of JavaScript.
You don't have to compile your
Java source
into JavaScript to see changes
in the browser.
I'll change the size of a sticky
note in my code...
refresh the hosted mode
browser...
and create a note
with the new dimensions.
Google Web Toolkit provides
an optimized RPC mechanism
for Java, which means
you don't have to worry
about the complexity
of low-level HTTP interactions.
Alternatively, you can also
easily use JSON
to communicate
with the server.
When you're ready
to see what your application
will look like in production,
you compile your source code
into JavaScript.
Google Web Toolkit handles
the browser implementation
differences for you, and creates
an optimized JavaScript file
per major browser.
The code is contained
in the cache.html files.
Browser-specific JavaScript
means a user
downloads only what they need.
An Internet Explorer user
doesn't download code
needed for Firefox.
The compiled script
is heavily optimized,
including compiler optimizations
like method inlining,
code size reduction,
such as removal of comments
and unused code,
and of course, the final script
is obfuscated and minified.
Now, if you want to inspect
the final JavaScript
in a human-readable form,
simply compile with the "pretty"
option selected.
Just be sure to switch back
to obfuscated before deploying,
as this results in faster code
and less JavaScript
for the user to download.
I've shown you the basics
of developing
with Google Web Toolkit,
the benefit these tools
can have
on a web developer's
productivity,
and the performance gains
you can achieve
in your AJAX application.
To learn more,
visit
code.google.com/webtoolkit.